[Music]
[Music]
and the playoff seedings is set Sims
Arena it has begun
hey hey hey it's our Argentinian helper
hey I'm back
we actually had a guy a fan from
Argentina DME the day that I got there
and said if there's anything I can do to
help you while you're on vacation let me
know where are you where can we meet
let's go he was he was he was too far
from where I was but I appreciate the
offer
why are you do we now have another mic
that works no only two today only the
New Year's Eve staffing so only two mics
working we're here on New Year's Eve
what do you guys celebrate New Year's
Eve - lots of vodka Oh vodka vodka
drinker I used to be it used to be a
really yes tequila took over me ideas
vodka just till a few years ago I used
to do Chopin on the rocket yeah but man
they just I feel like Joe's wedding
tonight right what up Joe and I'll tell
you what go Joe go Joe go Joe I'm just
gonna say this he's just gonna say this
last year I had my friend Evan's wedding
oh right and it was the year it was the
year that like Carson it was the week
Carson Palmer got hurt and all that
stuff yeah Aaron Rodgers got messed up
right and I came and I said that my
friend Neal looked at me and said Adam
we're winning the Super Bowl this year
and you said screw you Neil you don't
know what you're talking about and the
Eagles went on a run and they won the
Super Bowl last night I'm getting ready
for the rehearsal dinner and I'm
watching the Eagles and then Curt
Menefee comes on in the hotel room and
he goes we're now gonna peek in to
Chicago Minnesota and there's seven of
my friends I've known since I'm two
years old and Neal's sitting right next
to me and the Mensch tarik fricking
Cohen bounds his way into the end zone
and we're going nuts and Neil looks at
me and goes we're going to the Super
Bowl again ha ha ha no you're not Neil
sorry left go and your wedding friends
you're not going this is Chicago's here
they are the Eagles this year I don't
think it's a good matchup for you our
room for the
Aires hardcore this time around I'm
hardcore this is actually kind of good
it is good yeah screw you Eagle fans at
all left coast friends at the wedding
it isn't could you happen to dress
nicely it was a good well done yeah you
pulled it in on the bright spots and
everything Nick Foles 25 straight
completions Nick Foles gets bruised ribs
but he's still gonna come back right I
don't know it was a bad matchup for the
Eagles in 2001 when they went there and
won 33 to 17 with Donovan McNabb I don't
know look look if there's I love when he
goes back at 18 years one quarterback
that I'd like to face in this round yeah
we're facing them yeah I hear that I
hear that the only thing I'll say I know
we're getting off topic here I just
haven't covered agonize but they are
like you guys last year a little bit I
feel like yeah it's a Carson mean Carson
Wentz is in the second year it's true
risky in the second year you know their
defense is a lot like yours was last
year it should you guys are a dangerous
team there's no doubt about that I do
think this is a tough matchup for you
guys it is so much fun being the most
dangerous team in a playoffs yeah
because we all know those teams are it's
that wildcard Green Bay team right now
people are saying that about the Ravens
you know oh man I wouldn't want to play
them on any surface but the Eagles I've
experienced this before with Jeff Garcia
when they had that long run and it
didn't work out we were that team in o8
when we got in and went to the NFC
Championship game and lost to the
Cardinals right it's fun being the team
that no joke Vic if you throw that
interception to Green Bay you know we
got a chance right it's fun being the
team where we're kind of playing with
house money and nobody wants to face it
yeah I get that you are you got you got
you got a lot of confidence
battle-tested scars everything there but
s LFL the champion is it crowned yet
we're talking with meatloaf and we'll
get the winner on soon
come on meatloaf one other thing I want
to do that's very podcast related okay
before the year yeah would master 5000
said I want to make a bet with you guys
I think Blake jar win
I thought about it my three-times
yesterday his gut would would master yes
would rage master you mean you mean
would master one eyebrow he know he said
he goes you as I believe that Blake jar
one will have 35 catches and and you
said no way and he we said that if he
gets 35 catches yeah he gets to come on
the podcast right if he doesn't it's
gotta shave his eyebrow right well my
man Blake Charlie Wynn had seven catches
yes I was like what is he gonna break
the tie ten all-time record here and
break with hot stones and Blake Joran is
up to 27 catches ya sorry season's over
I want to ask you know playoffs don't
count if that's what you're gonna ask me
no he's shaving his eyebrows would
master get that damn thing out and send
us the video sorry
you've right and shared at your ass
can't cash you don't think it would be
fun for this game against Seattle on
Saturday to also have the added notion
of when dak rolls out and throw stab
like char when you're like son of it'll
make the game so much more fun he needs
eight catches all right fine if he gets
the 35 how about like wool we'll start
taking off centimeters off the eyebrow
okay so by each case he gets the 35 now
that we've been nice he has to do like
two lines in his eyebrows like 35 in the
play all right we don't remove that
right he's just doing line he I duel I
still think it's impressive that Blake
Darwin's gonna have 35 catches in the
year 2018 29 believable I thought the
number was 30 a lot of people do so when
I looked up yesterday and I was like oh
no gosh he's probably getting close to
30 I was like holy crap he's got seven
today Wow
yeah that was funny alright so we're
gonna break down all of the matchups on
set for Saturday and Sunday on Friday's
episode yeah well do a deep dive
Thursday if you want to look back at the
film from this past week if there's
anything that's you great yeah I also
feel like we're gonna have more coaching
fall out we're gonna get into that in a
second right but I just want to
establish the playoffs on this Saturday
the first game is Colts Texans Colts
knock off the Titans this is the team
that we wanted to get in the playoffs at
the Colt
yes this is the team that they
definitely did not want to see for the
Texas Exes did not want to see the Colts
I agree I think it's like the worst team
for the Texans to play unbelievable yeah
because what we've discussed this so
much right over the last month like the
Texans past defense they let up too many
big plays okay and the greatness of the
Texans past past defense or their team
in general that can help their past
events before right yeah yeah and we saw
in your game right against the Eagles
and lob it up your old line was big
enough and powerful enough to slow them
down a little bit and all sudden you go
home damn Nelson Aguilar its one-on-one
with Tyrone Matthews the safety 50 yards
of the field that would be scary because
that cold cold so line it's elite it's
arguably the best online in football and
they can stop that that password we just
get through all them atoms Saturday
night yeah Seahawks Cowboys awesome
great one guys realize the games that we
normally get on Saturday night it's like
a 20-point win by the Patriots over the
Titans or in the or it's like Houston
Raiders or bangles Houston or student
Raiders right well when it was Connor
cook against was it Matt Shoppach I want
to say it was TJ JJ Yates yeah all time
lock all time horrible so for our
Saturday early game to be luck versus
deshaun Watson yeah pinch me
yes 1:00 o'clock Sunday Chargers Ravens
rematch from week 15 awesome game
awesome it's the game that I'm having
the hardest time predicting who I'm
gonna pick to win yeah that's a tough
one to pick it is just because I love
the Raiden's but also who that knows
yeah I was it Yates versus Connor Cook
it was Connor Cook versus Brock Osweiler
Osweiler
68 and one touchdown Connor cooked
through for 161 one touchdown and three
interceptions yes that was the easiest
bet we made yeah that was that's right
and then the Sunday 440 is Eagles at
bears yeah
the team's the 1 seed went to the Chiefs
the two seed went to the Patriots which
is what we kind of expected one seed
went to the Saints won two seed went to
the Rams in the NFC which is your
tattoos they've lined up what week did
you do that I think that as I told you
that what was that week 9 maybe I want
to say it was around halfway week
9 Sims predicted Saints Rams Chiefs
patient wasn't crazy but it was I think
got that they were in the one in the to
labor the one on the two I was like yeah
but you know hey it looked like the
writing was on the wall a little bit at
that point and they certainly had been
consistent enough for me to jump on the
bandwagon soval for them of all the
wild-card teams yeah who's the most
dangerous I do think it's the Bears I do
I know the second-most danger probably
the I would look at the Chargers of the
Ravens and I look at the Chargers as
scary because they've been so good on
the road they're 7 and 1 yeah that their
game can kind of go anywhere and if you
score points on them that's fine they
also have our equation which is like the
two good pass rushers to kind of get to
the quarterback got a lot of things you
like it's only problem is they're
playing a team that's got like the
perfect formula if you were likely to
build a team to go I have to beat the
Chargers this week you would build the
Baltimore Ravens three top aligned
corners that cover the receivers you
know good safety play the bigness of
their team all that said I would agree
with you that the Bears are the most
dangerous yeah but actually I'm not now
I'm gonna say the team that I believe is
the most dangerous is the Colt yeah I
had a feeling you were understand
because I believe it's the highest
performing quarterback it's the scariest
offensive line he has time back there
and they have playmakers on defense that
they don't try and you're not gonna run
like they're gonna try and make plays
they're not gonna let you just sit there
and waste the clock yeah no they're not
there are needles are the most dangerous
but no you're right about that the Colts
are you know they realize they have some
deficiencies so they stun and do things
upfront with the defensive line and
sometimes they can be gashed in the run
game and sometimes they you know of
course their secondary is not great
where they can catch there but the Colts
are dangerous especially in the AFC I
mean in terms of our predictions yeah we
both predicted the Patriots to win the
East right I predicted the Ravens to win
the north you predicted the Steelers
right that worked out from me right
south I think we both predicted the
Texans I believe we did but I think we
also had the Jaguars making the play I
think so I think I might have ours with
the Colts I think I might have the
Jaguars and winning and maybe the Texans
in but I can't even remember I think I
don't think I did either I don't think
we both had the Chargers winning neither
of us accounted for the chimo I
chickened out on the Chiefs Patrick
mahomes and Thank You quarterback ever
five thousand yards 50 touched yes and
to do it the first marino no but Manny
Manny Manny in 2013 that year right when
he got fifty five and five thousand
which is the reason well that's a good
thought thank you it is a good thought I
thought about just this morning um but
the yeah that was special I mean come on
that year with Wes Welker and Demaryius
Thomas Wright all the yes that's where
all the trick plays kick plays bubble
screens all that stuff that's really
where the Seattle defense caught on fire
that's where it caught started because
defense is started to go wait we're
getting killed by these short passing
plays we got to start you know crowding
the line of scrimmage and that's where
the Seattle scheme became so handy and
that's why they beat the Broncos in the
Super Bowl that next year because it
took away all that kind of stuff mahomes
is definitely the MVP definitely the MVP
I mean again just some of the throws he
makes yesterday it's it's it's about the
quality of the plays you know he stats
are one thing but a 70 yard completion
that goes for touchdowns that's another
thing to me so when he makes big plays
they are game changing plays along with
it they're not just like stat fillers of
wow there was another great bomb in
between the 30s and then they had a
settle for a field goal he changes the
pace of a football game because of his
play clearly the MVP clearly in my eyes
I'm not trying to be a hater on anybody
clearly the guy this year it the Chiefs
scored over 26 points in every game this
year if the Chiefs get Sammy Watkins
back I am picking them to go to the
Super Bowl hands down this is crazy I
know because you were against them
forever I know you said that their
defense is too unreliable yeah so why
the change I just go look at the AFC
with no elite Mystere okay and I just
think that the Kansas City Chiefs on
trips would have to go all in the road
on the road and everyone's gonna talk
about to the Chiefs haven't won a
playoff game since Joe Montana was the
quarterback I get that that's great
awesome yes
well Patrick mahomes is the quarterback
now and he has a chance to be a Joe
Montana ish type
order back so this is all going to
change but I do think because there's no
elite teams in the AFC left go that this
is one of those years that even though
they have a big flaw that they can
overcome it with just sheer firepower so
when you say Lee do you consider the
scenes to be elite I do do you consider
the Rams to believe they've fringe on
that I think there's a third bet I think
the Bears are the second best team in
the NFC I do and I was curious how many
elite teams do you see in the NFL well
yeah right now hmm
that's a very good question I would
really look at Saints just the Saints
yeah as elite I would to say elite this
is one thing other thing I would put the
Rams the Chiefs I don't think you put
that well you would put the Patriots in
the same level as the Rams and the
Chiefs
you probably put Rams Chiefs bears yeah
and I put the Patriots right there with
it and then with the Chargers being that
one or they'd be a rumble no I think
they're right there too I do I think
they're all Groot lumped together I
think that's why it's such a fascinating
year we don't want one thing I always
look at its Chiefs Saints chief hold on
let me just bake this a nirmaan yeah if
we get a saint chief Super Bowl yeah one
it's gonna be entertaining as hell right
- it's gonna be mahomes versus breathe
yeah right I know it's going to be
mahomes versus gonna be your Super Bowl
I you're gonna hit Drew's gonna throw up
for 390 and you're gonna be like I hope
Patrick can throw for 500 I don't mean
it it's it's become so hard harsh I'll
be like what is this it's Tyree killer
I've never seen anything like this it's
like chimera by fast one thing I look at
sometimes when I look at teams and I go
just like correlating things through
history you know how you do sometimes
and you're just like a 2001 the version
you know I do the same crap yeah ours
but but one thing I do look at sometimes
for these type of situations overall net
points right there's a lot of people
look at this yeah I mean I think there's
something there to that and if you look
at the history of Super Bowl or the
Super Bowl fine finalists they're
usually the two teams who have beaten
teams most have come you exactly right
that their overall net point different
is leading their conference in each ways
when they lose it's not by a lot when
they win they think they shut teams out
they because they put him away like the
Kansas City Chiefs did the Raiders yet
all the time
[Music]
but I must had a good week cuz he didn't
lead the show off with it because he did
all of the Chiefs losses are by like
single digits yes and to like the best
teams in football and with all of those
games I would like to just again other
than the Seahawks game they had the lead
in the fourth quarter and when mahomes
had the ball last they win you know I
know and somebody the other day was like
wow they he had the ball last against
the Rams and I want to like
realistically last he had the ball asked
what the Rams with 20 seconds left to go
85 exactly oh come on don't do it all
all right oh you don't have to so in
week 17 of the regular season which many
people would say doesn't even count
because why would you bet on me I did
feel like yesterday before you miss
housing [ __ ] I felt like I was
cheating you I felt like I was GI I just
the thing I appreciate you the most is
your brutal honest yeah I did I was
going I mean they're going [ __ ] Kyle
Allen shut up because I you gave me a
lot of compliments the other day when we
did the show and you said you're like
Sims is really good this time in the
time of the year when it comes to the
meaningful games where Sims is really
good right because he goes I'll be
honest I've stopped watching Arizona
film for five weeks but I've watched
every snap of the Raven right so when it
becomes Ravens Chargers your insights
great thank the other ones are freaking
coin yeah the other ones and then some
of them that I might have one too I felt
like I was cheating you too because I
felt like damn I've been there I know
the emotions of we'll have teams feel
when they're in a scenario that you're
too smart for me no I'm just saying this
week right here at week 17 I've been on
a John Gurdon team when there's nothing
to play for and week 17 I know how that
week unfolds that's all I'm telling you
that's all I'm telling now I've said
that he say that anyway golly we both
went eight Nate okay and that's really
all the matter
Sims made 1450 on that bet which was so
big the rest of your games you went
seven and eight right meaning you lost
$10 so your total for the week was plus
1440 am i've lydon win any of those $10
that means in the last two weeks you've
made if people made your bets
yeah like around $3,000 which is insane
how do they do em guaranteed to lose cuz
we pick six this week we picked like
eight I know you picked the Jets to lose
they did you picked the Panthers to lose
they oh dang the Broncos the Raiders the
Bengals the Cardinals Washington and the
Titans oops oh I have it's like seven
and eight
yeah yeah final and I got Panthers game
I starred that on my notebook going I
don't know I didn't know any of your
bets that all I knew is I wrote go
Panthers next to it and I was like oh my
gosh they're winning 21 to nothing he
had 350 on the socks I lost 200 for the
week and that's it yeah of course but
that means that heading into the
playoffs Sims are you I took it you're
up 400 regular season champion right
here baby
season Sims yelled at me for celebrating
the regular season and said yeah whoo
haha I knew when I sent my text
yesterday and I said how are the bets
going and I got no response from my
friend Adam left go that they must have
been going good for me and Josh
responded and I knew then that they were
going very good I was drinking heavily I
would just like to point out that in
week 15 Sims was at negative 2,350
bleacher bucks left go was at 360 week
16 you made 0 Simms Simms came up to -
850 and then in the last week you pulled
Chris you pulled up to 590 and left I
lost 200 to go to 160
is it possible to go from negative 20
300 to 850 yeah how much is that what is
it is that well how far away is that is
that 1500 did he go past 1500 that we
got yes because I had the two big bets
right right
oh you right you went seven one seven
thirty and seven thirty again I was like
that's I went seven thirty and seven
thirty
yeah damn sorry sorry I don't even know
I'm lost in enjoyment right now I would
say that my regular season collapse yeah
is only a match by the Vikings man I'm
kind of like Nick Foles the picking
segment and you're Kirk Cousins well can
we talk there because I feel like I'm in
the unenviable position all the time
online of defending Kirk Cousins you're
good good for you you're a good man
yeah but but but don't worry just
because it's unpopular I didn't see
hardly any of that game what listen I
need you to explain to me what really
happened
they were dominated on offense I mean
they went through a period where it was
like late first half and they hadn't got
a first down yet they had nine yards of
total offense I mean that's that's how
bad it was so there was nobody open did
he miss a thrower - yes but he was under
pressure throughout they finally managed
a drive or two where he hit some
one-on-one completions Dalvin cook made
a run but it was ugly all day long they
were fighting an uphill battle yeah and
yeah I mean you saw did you see Adam
Thielen and cousin yeah what did you
take well the big thing I mean you can
read Kirk Cousins lips first of all he's
telling you I don't have ten seconds
like cuz Adam Thielen such a good route
runner and he wants to set up people so
badly he's taking too long and some of
those routes and Kurt's trying to
explain to him like I don't have time
for you to double move this is the Bears
who are playing and they're the best
defensive line in football and our
offensive line ain't that great so
you're gonna have to make some of these
things happen quicker if you want me to
get the ball to you and those are normal
conversations that go on and I thought
it was really good actually I thought it
was actually a good thing for Kirk
Cousins stop being friendly yes he got
you know when you're that guy right you
got to be you got to be an extension of
the coaching
have you got to be a little bit of an
[ __ ] and he probably needs to add
that into his game a little bit but
still his criticism is unfair it's I
understand he's one of the highest-paid
people in football and it's gonna come
with it but again there was just nothing
there I mean we saw their offensive
coordinator fired three weeks ago did we
really think it was gonna turn around
and this was gonna be some unbelievable
storybook ending at least I didn't and
they need to help him and he'll be
better next year
it's he's the only quarterback where his
salary is immediately mentioned right
after his name the only one so the top
six highest-paid quarterbacks this is a
post on bleacher report none of them
will be in the playoffs this year right
so that's Roger ROG is Ryan
Stafford cousins car and Garoppolo oh
man well I mean some of those guys just
don't even deserve to be on that list
that's what's that's what's the wrong
when they would say that would be drop
below car they don't deserve to be up
there yet but you know that's the
current state of the oh if you're good
and you had seven seconds of being good
as a starting quarterback oh my gosh
you're the franchise we got to pay you
25 million a year right now so yeah I
mean no no I just seen a lot of people
come for his neck no I agree I mean
didn't we say last week why is it that
everybody comes at him with the contract
stuff but nobody says anything about
Matt Ryan with Julio Jones and couch
nobody says anything about this is the
phrase they paid Kurt cousins 84 million
dollars to win games like this
that's the phrase I know it's the like
he's the only one player mm-hmm you know
they couldn't stop that bears rushing
attack that's that's Kurt Kurt's got to
stop that you're exactly right
it's not fair we've all done it we put
the quarterback to my nose same people
will go bears mine of the best defense
of the NFL brought worry and I'm like
you then then like you are aware of the
situation that he was facing yes I know
I I don't even if people talk out of
both sides of their mouth sometimes when
they get into bias or they find a
jumping-off point like a guy like Kirk
Cousins he's easy to jump on yes he's
easy he's Josh at the microphone and he
smiled in the postgame press conference
so that demeans he didn't care enough
because he smiled yesterday that some
people are saying that crap too it's
because of his too
meaner it's the extra office with the
notes it's the rocks that he keeps in
front of his house to measure time
there's nothing about Kirk Cousins when
you meet him or see him on television
that you go you are one of the best
professional athletes in the world right
and I think that's what happens is like
these reporters meet them and they see
him and they're like I've seen Cam
Newton
he's a transformer yeah I've walked past
Carson Wentz even Jared Goff you see
Jared Goff and you're like damn you're
like 6-3 6-4
yeah and you walk by Kirk Cousins and
you go if you told me you were the VP of
communications I'd ask for a wrench have
you told me you were Josh's older
brother yes yes right I'd be like I'd be
like I would be like you know probably
out lift right are you survivor boy
extraordinaire so a lot of people are
coming for his neck survivor for now he
was awesome we'll talk about that on
Wednesday though thank you yeah coach is
fired yeah we are at I believe that
there are seven total
Vance Joseph Dirk cutter Steve Wilkes
Todd Bowles Adam GaSe Marvin Lewis
we lost the one in Cleveland already and
we lost the one in Green Bay so right
now I have one two three four five six
seven eight jobs open the NFL I didn't
know Marvin happened officially I just
happened just as we came in yeah oh
that's the thing is we're recording this
at around 11 o'clock on New Year's Eve
during the day so things are still gonna
happen as it's happening at Marvin Lewis
yeah any of those surprising to you um
Marvin's a little surprising I guess
it's not surprising I know what I would
be interested in when Marvin is did he
want to go because I know in years past
the last two years usually decided to
part that's right there we go that's
what I was gonna say the last two years
everything I knew about that situation
from NFL people and coaching friends and
all that is that people were talking
about Marvin might be fired the real
thing was was Marvin going to leave the
bangles who I I don't know they're
they're gonna that's why there was
speculation a little there's a little
speculation that like maybe Zimmer has
his eye on that job out of Minnesota
he's got a house still close to there of
course he had a lot of years there's a
Steve
to coordinators secondary I don't see
that happening I know there's I don't
see that either I'm not retiring or
resigning period yes simmer according to
Ian Rapoport and Tom Bell right because
people were floating that yesterday
around the NFL either way though I think
the one that surprises me and I don't
know enough about this is the Steve
Wilkes one okay just to be one and done
like that and then for me to sit there
and again oh you dummy dummy dummy left
go just spilled his water since it's a
prequel to what the Eagles will do in
the playoffs this week exactly tip the
scales of power and spill on the table
for you to realize how meaningless it
was oh that was well said yeah but I I
don't understand what the the Arizona
one and the the talked out of there is
that Wilkes is over his head right that
right that he's more of a coordinator
than exactly right which you know again
first of all like why didn't you figure
that out before you hired him okay and
the guy that hired the guy that hired
him got a DUI and spent time in jail
this year okay and yet he's not going to
get fired and wanted to draft a mere
Abdullah over David Jones that's right
so there's like that's I just don't
understand that aspect of it sometimes
where the front office guy gets the free
pass and then the head coach gets very
Lombardi right hosted a quote from Bill
Walsh today yeah and it wasn't really
quotas more of like a story right but it
really said the the owner doesn't know
enough and and they they should know
more but they don't then there's the GM
and the GM kind of knows a little bit
but he's too busy trying to please the
owner and he's out to dinner with the
owner and he's saying hey we got this
then there's the personnel guy who
thinks he should be higher up but he
really goes there and he says all his
draft picks are good because the papers
say it's good right and all the
meanwhile you have a head coach and he's
there in the office until midnight every
night with his coach is trying to get
better but what happens there's a dinner
and there's the owner and there's the GM
and there's a player personnel and the
under goes why aren't we good right and
the GM goes well we got all the right
coaches we got all the right schemes we
got all the right players the director
of player personnel goes I drafted all
the right guys did you see that oh and
by the way they also said he should be
starting over him and he's not and what
do they do
they fire the coach meanwhile the coach
is why they're at that dinner he's
coaching he's working exactly and
they're at dinner and and Bill Walsh
said and this is why a GM will will
rarely lose their jobs every seven eight
years taking four to five coaches in
their wake and all the while none of
them know anything compared to the coach
yeah and it's completely true it is
completely true I mean dude we were we
work at a company you work at multiple
companies right I've worked at multiple
companies in my life and so of you it's
all caught it's all office [ __ ] it
is so out of office [ __ ] now why'd
that video not do well Oh probably
because the editors didn't put it in
time or it was the publishing team that
didn't know yeah everyone's just saving
their ass all the time you're right they
are and especially in the NFL that's
extremely political it really is and
yeah you know and to the point to like
may GM's are better at evaluating little
nuances than coaches most of the time
not always to give them credit there but
that is why the head coach GM
relationship is really important I mean
it really is and we've seen teams that
are successful that way you know whether
it be the Steelers you can say what you
want I mean they've been in the Harbaugh
newsom exactly right there you go
there's another Loyola chicken Belichick
balichek in Belichick which is really
Nick Kesari Oh up there okay Reid and
Ballard and right Ballard and right I
was just gonna go to Ballard and Reich
like that to me is them it looks like
perfect perfection Ballard really is a
astute evaluator of talent and he also
is the type of guy who is willing to
listen and his egos not too big to know
he'll also say Peterson and how we work
well together because Doug is a
risk-taker and how he's a risk-taker in
the way he it's the same way that you
won your offense to compliment your
defender
it's the reason the Ravens are so scary
and the Chiefs are so scary because they
fit together well that's why when I see
Jacksonville not fire Marone or Caldwell
yeah yeah I know I don't know that
that's good yeah well we know that's one
of the ones that actually have you going
yeah Dirk cutter makes sense right I
also think Jason lights should be he's
if he's on his last leg well that's
another example of what we were just
talking about it's kind of amazing yes
we'll see where that goes too though and
you know what like took his guys out
yeah they went to Hooters right they
talked about the game and I got it all
figured out it all figured out what
sounds like Bruce Arians is really gonna
be involved in that conversation down
there recent Jameis Bruce and Jameis
yeah
could be scary it could be I mean Jameis
really fits but couldn't you see him
once a year ago now less than James I'm
gonna tell you something you'll put a 50
points the game yeah and James is like
I'm down ya know like I I mean I still I
guess I'm somewhat amazed that they're
definitely sticking with Jameis but it
sounds like they've drawn a line in the
sand and they're doing that Vance Joseph
yeah popular discussion online right now
Sims is he's had like seven different
quarterbacks and none of them are good
and maybe the issue is lways quarterback
an analysis and not Vance Joseph's coach
i I mean I'm not gonna deny that if
there's been a flaw in Elwes GM career
it's the fact that yeah the quarterback
the last few years has been an issue but
you know again I think the real flaw
here is not Vance Joseph again I'll
point the finger at Elway and the fact
that he hired man's Joseph when he was
the defensive coordinator for the 29th
ranked team so far him over
Kyle Shannon Dave I mean that's really
yeah right and so now you're hearing I
know that there's some interest with
John Harbaugh there's also interest with
Mike Munchak there in Denver and then I
do think Mike Shanahan is still in the
fold
I do I think that legitimately I do I
think he is legitimately in the fold yes
a friend that raises yeah he's old he is
old I get that but he's still a stable
force he still really follows the game
and again I just would like to preface
this because everybody out there gonna
think I talked to Kyle I haven't talked
to Kyle Shanahan and like weeks okay so
everybody look at friends oh yeah so
this is I'm just letting you know these
are from contacts I am known throughout
the NFL Sims is very good at going oh
there's a dot and there's a dot and
they're connected right or and we're
then I hear I see a dot and I see a dot
and I go oh I think that might be
connected let me call somebody that
might know and then I don't know if
there's validity to my Adam GaSe maybe
in Denver I don't know enough there yet
I would I would think Senor oh no no I
just don't know enough about the Elway
Gates relationship all those type of
things I just don't know enough
I saw gays joining Patricia as the
see up there in Detroit maybe I could
see that that would work well together
Todd Bowles we've known about this for a
long time right your favorite would be
Jim Harbaugh right now I think Jim is in
the Jets I I mean I think the Jets want
Jim I don't know if Jim wants the Jets
but I do think that he is certainly he
is big-time on their radar yes and I
mean this Jim Harbaugh lose a little
luster after this weekend he should have
lost this luster that he has anyways I'm
just gonna tell everybody that he's he's
a really good coach don't get me wrong
Miami who do you think goes to Miami
they want John Harbaugh I also think
they want Jim Harbaugh that it's really
Steven Ross is an alumni of Michigan and
the business school is named after him
so he doesn't want to screw over his old
school timeout yes this is rich people
problems yes they're rich people
problems Steven Ross the back of his
head is going I need Michigan to be good
and I need the rights because he wanted
Jim the last time around when they got
gays so that was a very real topic I do
think again if things mess up in
Baltimore whoever that shakes out
interesting John like it's a thing I
know because I think it is a thing I
think it's also a thing so you're saying
if the Ravens lose to the Chargers look
out for John I think so if the Ravens
beat the charge grade like that like a
trade for John my question for you
though is is it Marvin Lewis is John
Harbaugh wanting to leave is he tired of
being in the same place where as
Baltimore - I think it's cuz they're
getting a new GM after this yeah I think
it's like could be somewhat mutual I
think it's a little Marvin Lewis I think
it a little bit a little bit yeah I
don't think he's gonna be disappointed
if he stays there but I don't think he's
afraid to leave is what I would say more
likely for him to be gone if he loses in
the wild-card divisional championship
how does it well I would think the
wild-card would be trouble I think if he
gets to the divisional game and like
goes into Kansas City and they barely
lose man they're gonna have tough if
you're gonna get rid of John Harbaugh
are you gonna do that especially with
like Lamar Jackson's record at that
point would be like seven and two
exactly including like wins in LA over
yeah that would be crazy that would be
crazy
um you already said Miami Oh Cincinnati
I mean I don't even know I don't know
that's where I'm like I don't know maybe
the one that hires Pat Fitzgerald out of
North
yeah it could be I mean hey I don't even
know what you're like there's gonna be
more candidates you know isn't gonna be
an Eric the enemy is gonna be a Bryan
Flores I mean there's just a lot of guys
I think they're gonna come out of the
woodwork here I just can't imagine walk
into Mike Brown's office and go and this
is the organization where I'm gonna go
for my first dip it's weird I know but
there's only 32 any any feelings more
about Green Bay or Cleveland no but I
was I thought it was interesting just
with Green Bay that you saw they're
going to interview Josh McDaniels
right so that is our dream I mean that
would be really cool to see Josh
McDaniels and Aaron Rodgers yeah crab
would be special brothers but that I
don't have any feel or inside info to
share there Brian Flores his name has
also been thrown out for a bunch of the
jobs did you say earlier in the year
that you did not think he was ready or
you think it's time for I dunno I think
he's ready I do I mean he's I would like
probably I mean you're perfect world
you'd go I'd like him to be a d
coordinator one more year right but
sometimes you don't have that luxury and
you just got to go when it's when you're
hot but he is hundred percent head coach
material
Brian Flores is a great defensive mind a
great worker and he is as tough and as
no-nonsense as any coach in New England
and I mean that more than Bill Belichick
I mean Brian Flores yeah he is
no-nonsense Brian Flores give me really
example of what I learned he was known
well first of all I've known him as I
know you're a lot of noms you know that
right and then well and I know and I
know no nonsense and I've seen it he's
from Brooklyn right he grew up in the
same town as like he's Brooklyn no he's
Brooklyn no nonsense grew up in the same
streets as Mike Tyson and all that that
area right so I got I love him right so
he's more so I'm not gonna name the
player okay but he was in charge of
scout team defense sometimes when when I
was up there in New England and there
was an offensive lineman he was had his
floor has had his foot on the ball and
showing the team the defense of scout
team the cards right typical right this
is what you do now the offensive line is
broken the huddle and he's not ready
so bites why his foots on the ball but
but offensive lineman starts to try to
steal the ball
from him and they get in the pushing
match I mean he doesn't back down even
though he was outweighed by 70 90 pounds
whatever he grabbed his face man he
didn't grab his face nice but then they
locked arms and he just he is fearless
like he is one of the coaches that if
you go like name me three coaches you
don't want to fight in the NFL he'd be
on the list right there I'm not messing
with him yeah but I think he is he's a
true New England you know how we talk
about sometimes New England guys only
know they're a little area he grew up in
the New England thing so he started out
as a [ __ ] boy just like me and he's
worked his way up the ranks
it is wild of the current eight jobs
that are open for the people that were
fired african-american I mean I don't
think that's that's just a number that
I'm putting out like well I mean for a
league that had all so they all got well
other than Marvin Lewis we got a short
amount of time yeah I I do not think the
optics are very good and then you have
the Raiders that the Raiders hire mike
Mayock did they even interview well they
were accused of this with the Rooney
rule I never didn't I know so I just yes
it's not a good look for the NFL in some
of these situations as far as hiring
minority coaches and not giving them
their chances you know but yet but yeah
the GM one who's been arrested a GM
who's been arrested and went to jail he
still has a job and an offensive
coordinator who drank around college
kids still has a job and got hired by
the NFL but yet we can't find anybody
else I that just bothers me I will say
in the Dolphins Chris Grier is being put
in charge of football operations like a
semi GM yes african-american okay but I
mean they're also losing Ozzie Newsome
this year to retirement and he was the
only african-american GM in the entire
league but my if the issue really there
is with the Raiders but I will say this
I mean their press conferences are going
to be oh they are gonna be amazing
here's mike Mayock and Jon Gruden I
write my cat right then Mike sitting
there he's like and the third string
fullback for the youth is quicker than
fast do you think mike Mayock is going
to be I think he's perfect for John
perfectly I do I think he's perfect for
John because I think he's just happy to
be in the NFL and be a GM even though
he's not a real GM because John calls
the final shot he knows every player's
roster right he's gonna already probably
have so much work done already or this
one's kid agreed but you think the
personalities are what excited I do I do
I think that Mike is the and I only know
Mike in passing but he's a really good
guy he does not have like a huge ego I
think he'll be willing to deal with
someone Gruden's crap at times and I
don't think he'll be scared of Gruden
either to go like no John I've watched
these ten players and you asked me to
make a tape and I think player 1 and 2
are the best like blah blah blah he's
not gonna be afraid to do that and
Gruden's gonna respect that he might say
no player 3 is better but he's gonna
respect that he has somebody strong
enough to stand up to him you just said
the phrase watch the tape yeah and
that's the reason I think they get along
yeah right I think Gruden respects
people that know how to watch game
filter more than other people and I'm
not saying Mackenzie didn't but it's
like Mayock stick yeah this is what
Mayer does he is he's he's had have you
liked his analysis over the years for
the most part I mean there's been a few
quarterbacks of course I mean you know
me the quarterbacks I'm always picky
with but for the most part yes I have I
mean I really have I can't say there was
a few here and there but you're never
gonna be perfect in the scouting world
all agreeing on on things I think that
this hurts the media more than anybody
because I think that a lot of these
writers relied on mike Mayock
I mean the amount of tweets that come
out of a mike Mayock phone or Prescott
yeah right it would it would it would
fill articles for two weeks yeah mike
Mayock third-ranked now like Daniel
Jeremiah you like the new draft expert I
would say so or Matt Miller
you know lands earlier but it's it's
interesting because you're friends with
Chris Mortensen and this was always
rumored with more that's something like
this would happen to him one day yeah
one day certainly but yeah more it just
didn't have the scouting area that may
academe I think to your point what
you're saying I mean his history knows
the whole league he already has a jump
start on things are really check
respects them exactly right and I think
there'll be there'll be a part of you
wanna when we were talking about
important relationships with the GM he
knows every GM in the NFL coaches need
to be able to trust the guy to cut out
some of the minutiae right like so like
he doesn't need to watch okay John might
go who with
ten best free agents okay well great
here's the 10 best free agents Michael
do the dirty work to watch 70 of them
right and then go here's the 10
and and John will be able to go okay I
trust I know this guy did his work and
I'm gonna trust it and now he's given me
the ten and we can go finalize it from
here - who the five we want are the
three what about this right what is the
biggest like festival of NFL people I
would argue it's the comedy yeah it's up
even more than the Super Bowl not all
coaches are going to the Super Bowl but
now most head coaches GM's front office
people go to the combine what's up
owners meet owners meetings up there but
it's not the whole NFL buy it's just a
head coaches are also getting Scouts
right and I would argue at that event
the most famous well-connected guy is
arguably mike Mayock yeah sure so you're
getting the biggest name at an event
where GM's make their money and the
biggest draft year and the history of
their franchise with three first-round
picks next two years I did not think you
were gonna be sold on Mike man they have
a they have a chance left go in my
opinion and if I'm the Raiders because
I've thought about this a little bit
where they have these draft picks okay
and then they obviously need to improve
their team and free agency if I'm them -
the one thing I'll say just diving into
that before we move on I would sign
young free agents I would I would not
the young core exactly built you're
gonna be a 10-year contract build
something special don't off of the
Julie's get an eye on your guy to fill
in and do that if you got some fourth
and fifth year free agents okay and you
maybe you got your one or two veterans
but now you have all these draft picks
coming up these fourth and fifth year
free agents they're gonna be in the same
mindset still of some of these rookies
but yet they're pros and they can go
know this is how you gonna do things
rook this is how we do it now and I
think that's where you can get you know
Seattle on top of the NFC West for seven
or eight years in a row or whatever it
may be that's how you grow that and
that's just be the angle I would take if
I'm the Raiders such a random thing to
happen but it's it's kind of cool that
Mayock me it is cool it is cool let me
ask you a question yeah when you saw
that did you go oh I could be in the NFL
front office oh yeah of course I do I
mean I just
one day hopefully that'll come or if I
want to go down that so you still want
to be in an NFL first part of me yeah
that came back at a perfect time Josh
yes there is part of me that yes will
always think about that always does this
make it feel more like feasible I mean
this hey guys like John Lynch all those
things have made it more feasible to me
I know I'm capable of doing it like I
said even if I got offered right now I
wouldn't want to do it because of the
stage of life I'm in with my kids and
everything but it's just something that
yeah I look at I always feel like I'm
missing one part of my journey which is
a Super Bowl ring I always wanted that
that was the dream of mine so that will
always be in the back of my head
philosophies that we saw yesterday yeah
the Cowboys rested Zeke Zack Martin some
other people but played deck yeah
the Bears went all out right what a
dangerous
the Patriots really went all out yeah
Jets blew sumin a / - oh my gosh I know
a game could have been a lot closer
could have been like tied right early at
halftime but what did you think about
the Cowboys and bears strategies yeah I
guess
I think the Cowboys I look at the
Cowboys and Patriots kind of being in
the same boat where they were gone our
offense has been underwhelming our
quarterback hasn't been great our
receivers haven't been great we need to
work on some things offensively and they
went with the mantra of like practice
makes perfect let's go out there and get
dak throws I think the Dallas Cowboys
were are being realistic and going we
can't expect to go to New Orleans and
win a 13-10 game we might have to score
30 next time yeah and our quarterback
and passing game need to be hitting on
salsa actually great he did he made some
big-time throws so I think that was a
positive moment for that matter team
touchdown at the end what that was a
great throw amazing catch Cole Beasley
man amazing and then what about the
Bears going all out because I'll be
honest yeah I would've rather played the
Vikings I hear you I know they're you
know they're a young team that's still
building they don't want to take their
foot off the gas pedal momentum wise I
think there is still a team that looks
at their office and goes there's things
we need to continue we got a young
quarterback who's not always perfect I I
would think also they're a little bit
like you know I mean Minnesota third
time it's a lot better for the Bears to
finish the season five and three on the
road
instead of four and four because they're
gonna have to go on the road in the
playoffs sure there's there's there's
positives about it and I think the other
thing too you know how I talked about
the psyche of the Bears last week right
like it had been weird if the game was
13 to 10 and even though if they pulled
their starters at some point in
Minnesota one it was gonna be a positive
from Minnesota they're gonna go oh look
we were hung in there and we beat them
we can do it again this week and the
Bears were gonna go damn we couldn't
really put them away and they took us
out it was only 1310 I'm not sure so
that part of the psyche was intriguing
to me leading up to the game so the
Bears just said no screw you you're out
of here you're not playing us again
we're gonna move on and yes is scary as
the Eagles are I think that was the
right play
get your team better win the game going
with positive vibes got some good reps
with the running game true Biscay and
now you played the bear the Eagles in
this NFC year yeah we looked at the NFC
East and the NFC West and when the
Seahawks are down we expect them to be
around eight and eight Niners aren't
gonna be an issue Cardinals are gonna be
an issue the East is a muddled mess and
yet those are the two divisions that are
getting two teams in I know you're only
getting the Saints and if I told you
before the year that you were getting
one team in the NFC North it was either
gonna be the Vikings or the Packers yeah
we liked the Bears right but we thought
they would be fighting for the 60
exactly but the only team that made it
in the North
yeah I know hi oh I know it's while just
shows you the NFL few players in free
agency a coach coaching change you know
what it shows different depth yeah this
is the number one thing that I look for
in a team its depth yep
Vikings did not have depth Packers did
not have depth they couldn't survive a
whole year no no depth and then no
Hawkins had their death tested exactly
right and all those offenses you're
talking about I would say or limited
schematically those three right off the
bat it's just it's limited schematically
to where you go the quarterback has to
play great every week or they can't win
games who do you think realistically I
look at it as scary as Eagles are I'm
not trying to even mess with you or
anything here I really think the Bears
match up better with the Eagles and they
do the Vikings you know I again
yesterday as much as they were
dominating that game their starters were
in and it was 13 to 10
why do you think that the Vikings are a
worse matchup than the Eagles well I'm
because what the Vikings have an
offensive line that could be taken
advantage of I think the Eagles have a
better often they do have a better
offensive line but you don't have as
good receivers okay I would say that I
would argue yeah I would argue that
against the Bears the receivers that the
Eagles have are better fit
I'd rather lob it up to al Sean then
wait for a Thielen route to develop yeah
I think that the Eagles like there's a
there's a few parts of the Eagles that I
think are great mismatches that one of
their best receivers is a tight end and
Zach Ertz is as a weapon that the
Vikings didn't have this Darren Sproles
piece sure I just want to say that when
the Eagles beat the Bears and they go
into the Saints having a guy like Darren
Sproles that played there and Malcolm
Jenkins is really good to be great for
this one will be helped but they have
like these little Pete like the Al Shean
lob you weren't lobbing it up to feelin
I don't think no I could be speaking out
of my ass rate no you're you're not
you're not your scheme is better than
that's repeaters and a Brooks and a
Johnson and a Kelsey have a higher
ceiling of maybe may be blocking Khalil
Mack every now and right then the
Vikings effort I don't disagree with you
anything there I mean you're right and a
lot of things there defensively though
that's where I would be worried my
because I will say this that there was
the are gonna be able to block your D
line oh yeah you know I mean there's no
on your secondary yeah that's where I
just look at it but it was close I'm
just saying it was very close
Minnesota's defense always scares me I
mean they're good they're good and then
you know the Xavier roads might have
been back next week to deal with that
sir I just go yeah they can be game
changers and that I just think though
that the way Zimmer coaches he wants to
be in a 13-2 Jeff he does Doug
Peterson's gonna go and who's gonna know
Nagy more than Doug sure they coached
together in Kansas City a lot of great
knowledge there and both of them Oh baby
so I also like I look at the team's the
Eagles have done it the Vikings are like
let's prutte late like we got to prove
to ourselves so you're definitely more
dangerous that way I mean the Eagles can
got there and go may y'all ain't done
[ __ ] try Biscay Fletcher cogs a look at
your biscuit be like I'm gonna eat you
alive who was gonna do that on the
Vikings no no one I get that okay my dad
texted me like two seconds ago we could
beat Chicago you're still gonna lose
sorry Bruce Brown's interested in Matt
Eber flus only other game that I had for
you okay I really want to talk about
before a run out of here to go and do
wedding directors and all that stuff
Ravens browns yeah what do you think of
the game because I'm not talking about
tights Colt so we knew what that was
yeah well we knew that was gonna happen
Blaine Gabbert delivered and clutch so
I'm thankful that the Titans didn't make
it in just say that all the Tennessee
fans we're not that are upset yeah it
was it was just for our playoff
enjoyment it's not about you know I'm
like I would apologize to the Vikings
fans - that sucks
you know but you know you yeah not the
way of the Eagles and the Colts sorry
yeah that's right that's right and
Tennessee just they're not there yet
that's just all there is to it there
have got a lot of things that are
positive and they should feel good in
that round but Ravens Browns I mean it's
what Lamar Jackson is doing in that run
game it's it's amazing I don't even know
what else to say about it I mean they're
running like it's like the Oklahoma
wishbone they're running but in the NFL
it's their size and physicality matching
up with that and then the scheme of the
run game I mean again Greg Roman
deserves a lot of credit there in
Baltimore for what he's doing Greg Roman
who invented the Colin Kaepernick
read-option offense in San Francisco he
is there as the run game coordinator in
Baltimore and they do great creative
things weekly that really test teams in
the NFL
so that was awesome Lamar continues to
grow in the right direction and their
defense is scary but even saying all
that man Baker's appalling Baker is fun
to watch that was a tough tough
environment against a really good
defense but I have a feeling where it's
not the last time we're gonna see that
matchup go down to the wire where do you
see the Steelers not making the playoffs
did you know that the Ben Roethlisberger
hasn't made the playoffs five times in
his career all five times it was by one
game and we'll all five times it was a
season in which he lost to the Raiders
oh is that right that is crazy that
really is but where do you stand with
your with your
bowl stealers not making the playoffs
yeah because if they made it they could
have gone they cut a gun right no no
doubt
they got nobody to blame but themselves
they messed it up there's there's really
nothing but it started a weak one that
was like a microcosm there they had a
control of the game against the
Cleveland Browns and they snapped the
ball into the dirt and Big Ben got
blindsided
James Connor fumbled on inside their own
you know 5-yard line where the Browns
got at the one-yard line
it's kind of what they did all year that
was really it they found ways to mess up
in big situations or situations where
they had a chance to win a game and put
it away and they let another team hang
around yeah it stinks it does stink but
the six we got in are pretty damn good
so I'm not too disappointed yeah all
right I have a bunch of tabs open for
reddit I'm gonna run through some little
nuggets and we're gonna get out of here
because I think they're fun Baker
Mayfield breaks rookie passing touchdown
record with 27 touchdowns and he only
played 13 games yeah it's awesome
I mean Baker Mayfield superstar he's
he's I mean the young quarterbacks I
don't know what else to say they're
they're [ __ ] phenomenal Josh Allen
right oh by the way I lost my Miami
Buffalo hushed on both right damn to him
not there's nothing like waiting for
months to watch Josh Allen just destroy
it with his legs and his arm he's
phenomenal I know throwing it to Kyle
Williams was so freakin cut was really
cool Sam darn old played well at the end
of the year did rosin rosin tough about
it's a top of that evaluation they're
more and greater awesome the big thing
with rosin I think is gonna be what
we've always said can he take the
punishment and can he get out of
punishments way it's my only question
about his slow decision-making and
throwing is off the charts what do you
got I was just gonna say are you feeling
good about Lamar cuz you took a beating
when you ranked him number one and then
I know you dropped him down to four yeah
but he's been awesome yeah he's been
awesome it does feel good yes it feels
good for him and then I feel like I took
a beating with Josh Allen too and I feel
like nobody really wants to give Josh
Allen credit even though he led his team
in passing and rushing he has LeSean
McCoy on his team and he led his team in
rushing you know that's that's an
amazing feat and I know the Sean McCoy
was banged up and didn't play the whole
year he runs for like 40 yards on so
that's what I mean I don't say this
what's awesome yeah
that fanbase watch it cuz I watched
bills yeah I gotta get my on it too
they they're appreciate they love it
right right yeah they know what they got
yes it's Peter King wrote this in his
article this morning about MVP and he
said Zimmerman always told him go with
what you see yeah when I watched my
home's I see something special yeah when
I watched Josh Allen yeah I see
something special now it's not every day
you could see a guy throw at 70 or run
for seven right
by the way Lamar Jackson will be the
youngest quarterback to start an NFL
playoff game does Baker oh is that right
this Baker or sake wanwan Rookie of the
Year so I just gave you the Baker News
yeah sake one surpasses 2000 yards from
scrimmage becoming just the third rookie
to do so I believe that because the
Browns were closer to a playoff I think
that if Baker eliminated the Ravens said
he definitely won the one definitely
what I wanted yeah I understand giving
it to either but I believe that se Quan
did it for an entire season he set the
record for most receptions by a rookie
running back he goes over 2000 scrimmage
yards and for all of those people that
are gonna blame the offensive line for
Eli say Quan did that behind that
offensive line with no odell for the
last four weeks it was all say Quan and
I'm just gonna say that his leap from
the 4 yard line yesterday doesn't say
that touchdown right was in the top five
plays of the year say Quan has given us
big runs against Jacksonville that we
hadn't seen up until that point
he's literally beaten teams by himself
second leading rusher and football
behind the same crappy offensive linemen
that we talked about that Eli Manning
gets the benefit of the doubt I just I
know I'm just I'm just reinforcing it
it's just amazing I don't think he's
really getting the credit than what he
deserves
he averaged 5 yards per carry with a
check down Charlie quarterback and a
crappy offensive line that's insane I
believe that say Kwan and mahomes are in
the same thing right now where we're not
appreciating their greatness because
they're too great yeah I think you might
be right it's like so easy it's been too
easy that was like them flick that 70
yarder that's not
Fairey we fawn over my it took a no-look
pass for us to talk about mahomes
throwing but meanwhile like those bombs
yesterday no one else may throw 55 yard
bomb off the wrong foot for the
record-breaking time I already went on
my ran I think se Kwang's work of the
year but whatever yeah okay yeah that
it's it's it's really a good one all
right your last thing for you and these
from around the Giants are they gonna
trade Odell Beckham jr. my question to
you would be who do you think they'd
even think about it - well I I do think
the 49ers would think about that I think
there's number T my Eagles friends
yesterday right me what I trade if Nick
Foles wins our Super Bowl would you
trade Carson Wentz for say Kwan I paused
I mean the Raiders with their draft
picks you got a lot of oh you're
thinking Odelle Raiders who was the
first I'm just saying I'm the 49ers well
Buffalo you want to make Josh Allen work
I mean you know I just think there's a
number of teams you can look at that
there's two things I just know the
Giants I don't know any of this this is
no inside info you know Francesa
and he's got it he's got a connection is
his sauces are telling him get out of
here my sauces are telling me you know I
love Odell Beckham jr. I do not think
he's necessarily the Giants cup of tea
it does seem like they're gonna keep Eli
Manning why even pay Odell Beckham jr.
of Eli Manning's your quarterback that's
the question I would pose to everybody
out there he is not going to be able to
maximize Odell's talents and the Mehra's
Odell speaking out doing the little
Wayne crap not playing every year I just
feel like I don't know this I'm talented
throwing this I just it does seem like
that's a possibility I'm just saying it
you know where Indy know that would be
amazing that could that could be a
possibility too with all them and the
great thing is if you trade for Odell
right now they've already paid him 21
million dollars in D has the salary cap
to a four now
Indy should go and trade for Odell and
sign Le'Veon Bell and it should be
Andrew Luck Oh del T why Eric Ebron Jack
Doyle and Le'Veon Bell Marlon Mac naheem
Heinz that would be that offensive line
can you believe that offensive line they
are some let me say this one more time
yeah Chris Ballard friend of the show
right trade for Odell sign Le'Veon Bell
build the super team do it yeah
and then trade for Jalen Ramsay because
they're done with him - oh by the way
yeah that story with Jacksonville right
possibly voiding the guarantees of
Leonard fournette yeah and attributing
it to his suspension the bills is the
exact reason why we said that ro kwan
smith should not sign that contract
right because that's exactly what just
happened a Leonard fournette that's
right Leonard fournette might be gone
that was a bad look for them yesterday I
saw it happen live show him yeah he kept
showing they were sitting on the
sidelines and the offense was on the
field and they were sitting there having
their little private conversations and
to me it looked like they were ripping
people on their team because they were
covering their mouths as they were
saying it it just didn't look good they
might have been talking about hey what
are you gonna get your mom for happy new
years whatever but no it looked like
they were talking crap and bitter and it
just didn't look right it's not looking
good for Leonard fournette and that
draft class because if you look at it
two miles Garrett try Biscay Salomon
Thomas Fernet there's Jamal Adam there's
Patrick mahomes at ten I know
and there's deshaun Watson at 12 yeah
and if they don't keep Fernet yeah and
you know yeah you passed him up right
that's gonna look bad you're right I
could say this Fornetti
sake one no nobody is sake one and I
trust me I love for net coming out and
you know that I love to zekiel Eliot but
when I watch sake when I was like as
much as they were great those - they're
not sake one George Kittel breaks Travis
Kelsey's record for most receiving yards
by a tight end on a meaningless 40-yard
touchdown as the game was going down he
also was number one in the NFL this year
in yak
that's amazed by all positions George
Kittel friend awesome so happy for him
yeah great guy and I hear that there's
two Iowa tight ends coming out in this
year's draft that are projected to go in
the first round wow I didn't know it was
two of them I knew there was one but man
that that's say Iowa her friends George
Kindle could do this for the next six
seven years he definitely can I mean
he's got the right OC to that knows how
to utilize them you know this Kyle had a
Jordan Reed early in his career with the
Washington Redskins he knows how to play
with these kind of guys Mohamed Sanu in
a hundred and twenty two fewer attempts
has more career touchdown passes than
Nathan Peter
he now has four Tyler Lockett finishes
the season with a perfect 158 point 3
passer rating when targeted Larry oh is
that right so if you if Russell Wilson
threw the ball to lock it it was
complete it was a good thing I had Tyler
Lockett on my fantasy team yeah and
every week it would be like three
catches one of them for 60 yards right
touchdown right but there's that usually
should regress it never regrets yeah I
got a few more here yeah good Tom
Coughlin's talking about TJ Yeldon and
Leonard fournette mm-hm tarik cohen
letting Khalil Mack into club dub I
already did the one about Roethlisberger
Jameis Winston coming back the void
guarantees nick foles needed to play
four more snaps to get a million dollar
bonus because in his contract it said if
he played 33% of the snaps
but his rib injury cost him 1 million
dollars I'm gonna be honest I'm not
coming out yeah you gotta be aware of
that Nick well I wouldn't be shocked if
they even gave it to him here at the end
I wouldn't be shocked it would be also
just another thing just to say thanks
for the Super Bowl and you know I did I
don't know I haven't heard anything
horribly wrong yet so I would think he's
gonna play this we have four good
nuggets left yeah
69 games were decided by three points or
less this season yeah an NFL record
right never been that many it's gonna
continue to go that way because the the
rules the way they are you know oh we're
down let me throw it in the triple
coverage will get pass interference
it'll be first down in a 50 yard gain I
mean it's just the games never over
anymore because oh you're right
fingernail touched the quarterbacks neck
illegal hitting of the head to the
quarterback I got down I got three
Nuggets here right do you want Warren
Sapp Bill Belichick or Blake bortles
this is how we're gonna end our New
Year's podcast well let's go best to
worse so we'll go Bella check one the
Pittsburgh Steelers have had three head
coaches since 1969 Belichick has beat
all three of them Chuck Noll Bill Cowher
Mike Tomlin wait you sure you beat Chuck
Noll Chuck Noll the year was 1991 he was
the head coach of the brown dam and he
beat the Steelers
17 to 40 that's amazing that's the one I
would have yeah I didn't realize Chuck
was still there in 91 that's unreal the
deciding score was a Kevin Mac one-yard
touchdown
Kevin Matt Matt Stover kick number 34
with shoulder pads the size of
buildings-- Warren sapper Blake bortles
I said best to worst has Aaron Donald
already had a better career come on Sam
both our four-time All Pro yes Donald is
gonna be in his fifth Pro Bowl Warren
Sapp was at seven Aaron Donald is six
forced fumbles behind
he already has more tackles for losses
and he's about 30 SEC's behind in a
hundred and twenty less games wow that's
impressive in eight les seasons I don't
know if I'm gonna say he's surpassed
them yet he has the ability and is going
to surpass him I mean we know Aaron
Donald he might go down as the greatest
D lineman in the history of football I
mean that's he's gonna say this about JJ
Watt a few years yeah well it's the same
there same type of guy I mean JJ Watts
going to be in that conversation when
all said and done you're gonna go okay
Reggie White Lawrence Taylor JJ Watt
Aaron Donald's they're gonna be in that
combo that's the guy though in my
opinion the Jordan of defensive lineman
Reggie White right he's only gonna
because he has the mythological stories
about it but then again they probably
said the same stuff about Deacon Jones
when he retired right I mean Warren Sapp
is amazing he was if he had Aaron
Donald's work ethic I think he would be
Aaron Donald I'm not trying to take a
shot at him there but they were just
different guys that way but man I mean
Aaron Donald is 20 and a half sacks
it was insane what he did how close he
was to three other ones when he caused
three turnovers because he hit him as he
was throwing or he couldn't he had to
throw up a ball without a full follow
through and it gets popped in the air I
mean he's just such a difference maker
that way last one yeah to wrap up the
2008 get the luxury to just fly up the
field like Aaron died right so that's
just the one thing I would push you if I
was a little different that way what's
that say that was just about Erik be
enemies getting interest with the New
York Jets yeah I get that here our Blake
bortles
last 20 drives against the Texans and
before I say this I'd like to remind you
David Caldwell is being brought back to
the organization last 20 drives against
the Texans this year punt punt fumble
punt punt punt punt fumble punt field
goal punt punt punt punt end of half
punt punt punt punt interception and I'd
like to state at the field goal that
drive started off at the Texans nine
it's amazing that's amazing yeah I don't
know what to say
muff punt it's that's pretty pretty
despicable first of all I don't
understand how Nathaniel Hackett was
fired there and you want to talk about
it offensive coordinator who needs to be
hired by somebody and you know yeah his
dad
Nathan Hackett's dad coached me so say
what you want bias or not I don't really
give a damn I'm just telling you the
truth the truth here he deserves to be
an offensive coordinator football I mean
you could see the Jacksonville offense
was a lot better when he was up and
running plays or calling plays than it
was afterwards I don't understand how he
got released there but I do think that
that was unfair to Nathaniel Hackett
either way and yes what do they do with
Blake bortles it's been a culmination of
a lot this year a lot of things coming
to an end but I think that we were
proven to be right about bortles I think
that we were proven to be right about
mahomes Brees I I would say that most of
our playoff picks were good except for
my Green Bay pick and I guess your
Pittsburgh pick so in essence your pits
were picking my green payback we're
exactly the same as they were the same
yep they were so I'm rooting for the
Texans and you're rooting for the Saints
on you yeah I think if you made me pick
right now yeah I'm gonna say Saints
Chiefs Super Bowl what do you guys say
what are you gonna say give me a just a
we're not gonna hold you to it we're not
gonna make a video of it just tell us
there's one thing I have to do right now
are you gonna pull the team's hope the
team's
I want to see does NFL Jesus have a I
mean a ton punt punt punt punt punt punt
that is that is truly unbelievable first
a Texans defense that's what 29th and
football and pass defense I mean that
just kind of says it all right there I
don't know I don't even know what to say
I don't want to do it what I don't want
to do it
yeah the Saints Patriot Saints Patriots
yeah that's we're gonna pick that would
be the worst wouldn't be the worst but
the beep I'd be cool really the it would
be cool I'd probably be the oldest
combined starting quarterback ages in
the Super Bowl history all right homie
all right party the Happy New Year what
are you gonna do you gonna drink I know
my cousin and nephews
they're gonna be there yep I am gonna
drink I don't care kids are around all
right
my kids will be there hey all right is
that gonna make this make the cut
yes I don't know if I'm going to drink
I'm definitely going to smoke my my
smoke my worth's there I am definitely
gonna get after it well daddy cigar just
little daddy cigar back pork back porch
action and then is it going to be
tequila on the rocks or not I don't know
yet I don't know if I have to tie him
have to make a game-time decision can I
get a little spiritual and everybody
really quick my one thing would be would
be a lot of times when people wrap up a
year they go to the next year they think
of all the things they want to do and
they look around and really look at the
people that you have around you because
I think that's the most important thing
Aristotle believed in three types of
friendships he believed in utility he
believed in pleasure and he believed in
goodness utility is when you do
something for me and I do something for
you and thus a friendship is born out of
necessity pleasure is about like kind of
living in the present and it's about
feeling that joy but those friendships
don't really last as long because it's
more about like let's have fun right now
and then goodness is the one that
everyone seems to believe is the most
rewarding it's where I have mutual
respect and it goes back and forth and
we strive for goodness between us both I
would argue that to everybody out there
try and do all three and 2019 try and do
things for people without expecting
anything in return
try to live in the moment and not get
too caught up in going forward but I
would end it with this and I said this
to my friend Joe as I spoke with him and
his future wife tonight that go for
greatness and not just goodness so try
to always bring value and I know that
everyone has probably said this is gonna
be the year's gonna be the year I lose
way this is me I do this [ __ ] this is we
are I accomplish my dreams [ __ ] do it
it just
starts off by waking up on Tuesday or
waking up on Wednesday and going I'm
gonna do it I'm not gonna do the dumb
[ __ ] I'm gonna do the good [ __ ] one day
at a time one day at a time just
approach that but every day you wake up
that's why football players say it
that's what it is all you can do is
control that day that's win that day and
then build from there yeah and it's you
know just because they're athletes
doesn't mean they're superheroes they're
just humans that wake up every day and
they have a lot of conviction so I wish
the same for all of you [ __ ] I
love you guys homies you're the best and
have a great 20 19 have a great 20 19
Happy New Year and don't forget the
Picts champion Chris Sims will be here
on Fridays podcast to further your
pocketbooks as the big champion I can't
wait for you to raise your
regular-season banner for six C's at
home more fendron good evening everybody
and for the LEF koe we will holla holla
holla at you in 2019
[Music]